[Music]
welcome to hot seat it showed the
hardest season even in the evening hot
requests
no he did it he did here we go johnny so
uh so welcome to hot seat this is a show
where we try to we try to turn up the
heat during the conversation and we hope
that we hope that you enjoy the
conversation so
to start it off we got bart with the
coldest question in the house
if you owned
a marshmallow factory
what shape would your marshmallow be in
everyone collectively around the world
just leaned in
that is a great question um i don't know
why the star david came to me first i'm
not even jewish i just think it would be
cool to have a star david kind of fluffy
yeah it'd be a cool like star dip and it
has like the holes in it so it's like
yeah oh you would have holes in the
starboard yeah like a star no like a
star david with like the whole thing i
think that'd be
i already know i could visualize what
section that would be in yeah that
section and the jewish section
the kosher where the matzo balls are
yeah i don't know if it's kosher just
because it's a star david thing i don't
know if it is yeah no
yeah
any questions
i don't even know where to even go with
that anybody else have a hot seat
question
okay i got a hot seat question have you
ever um had a pet that you loved
and have you uh how was saying goodbye
to that pet was it
what was that like um i actually had two
two childhood dogs die so crazy story um
my childhood like my one childhood dog
that i loved um i was shooting my first
episode of power and i'm literally on
the way to set and my mom accidentally
texted me and said um butters just died
don't tell gianni he's filming the today
oh
where was it going to it was going to my
brother um
and my older brother lived like lived at
school for a while so he wasn't like
close to the dog so he like didn't
really have a like it was my dog i got
like all the stuff and my mom texted me
this and i remember just being like
it's like go go yeah like going
anyway on set like did it were there
extra emotions you could i actually it
was a pretty high comedy scene so yeah
way better yeah well you need that right
yeah kind of yeah that darkness yeah
look i'm just gonna pretend you know
um but yeah so that was that was the
story of my childhood dog dying what
kind of dog was it it was a cavalier
king charles was a dead dog
did you tell your mom like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you texted the wrong person yeah i
did i just said yeah you you texted me
and she's like oh sh and then she did
like that astrich marks t should go like
jk
she's like you know he's dead i'm like
but yeah oh [ __ ] where'd you grow up i
grew up in rhode island providence rhode
island oh okay that's a pretty cool
place don't they say all the [ __ ] come
from
risd yeah they actually do
how do you know that
we did a show you did a show at brown
really just making this [ __ ] up no
that's that's like everyone's other oh
yeah all the salutes go to me so they
they
apparently the students at brown
they're like the girls here suck so
let's go to risd because that's where
all the girls are art school they like
to party and the real context is these
guys go out there they're like hey where
can we find the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what's that
when you were a kid did you already know
what you wanted to do
um
yeah when i was probably around like
12 12 when i like when all the coaches
are pushing you then is that what got
you to do it or is it other people
telling you you you can i knew i wanted
to do it but i always would like my
parents also when i was 10 i was living
in canada and flying to every country
all the stuff playing hockey so in my
mind i'm like my parents a would never
let me do anything else other than this
at this point and b they put so much
money and everything into this i'm like
i can't just be like hey um yeah i want
to go do theater in a [ __ ] black box
you know a small theater
you know an encino they'd be like what
the [ __ ] um so i but i knew what i
wanted to do uh it just had to like get
how was it breaking it to them that you
weren't gonna be a pro hockey player
um so i i like lied to them i was like
oh i'm moving to la um i gotta like
rehab my shoulder my shoulder got hurt
like all this stuff and i told my dad i
was still gonna play the next season i
just kind of wanted to go figure out my
life in la for the summer and then i got
an agent within like the first couple
weeks i was here and then um i was like
yeah i'm not coming back
and i never touched my hockey bag your
parents like pretty upset with you was
your dad my mom was super supportive my
mom was like um
uh
go chase your dreams like do what it
like do you this is your life like so
your mom all your coaches everybody in
your life was like you gotta chase your
[ __ ] dreams yeah
they all wanted you to stop wow yeah
yeah have you seen any adversity at all
perfect yeah my my [ __ ] high school
girlfriend she [ __ ] started dating
someone else and that's what pushed me
through all the classes the whole time
the funny thing is
fake [ __ ] you're not joking right now
does that really happen no i didn't of
course not dude of course i do my
childhood girlfriend [ __ ] loves me
she hits me up all the time
she misses the perfect guy
[ __ ] yeah dude
a perfect
[Laughter]
i bring a more feminine energy to the
room no jiu jitsu bro no
[Laughter]
so yeah
oh you don't have a girlfriend okay so
we all know that all all [ __ ] actors
that are successful slay puss how many
of you had you know let's get a body
count like oh it's so warm yeah
this seat got a little hot
um i mean i you know
he can't even keep counting this guy
yeah the perfect
are we talking about this week
yeah i've been in a foursome yeah
all chicks and you yeah
i'm not gonna lie like i i do think
about that a lot i'm like that was cool
did you ever let your bros join in
um
it's a ratio thing what about the [ __ ]
boys
bro i i just think it's it's too like uh
it's just a risky thing where it's like
yeah like if some girl was like yeah
there was four dudes here it's like it's
just weird you know what i mean i just
don't want to like why four though i
don't know or i don't know that was what
came to my mind like all the bros being
like yo my next like yeah if you're
boating four chicks which one gets the
jizz
how do you qualify
his eye
whatever one makes you come you know
we'll get it's like that's good yeah
that that's also like like really safe
yeah it's just like whoever yeah i know
i'm like the hottest one obviously
no no no the one who who makes you know
we have a lot of actors uh sit in that
hot seat and they always answer this
question um shittiest uh co-star actor
you've ever worked with
uh i've honestly they always give first
last name soon i've not i've not had
anyone that's uh bad
besides um
michael rainey jr who's my co-star no
i'm kidding
no literally i've worked with just great
people like there's there's no one that
has ever very safe as well sometimes
there's people who like have uh weird
energy like while you're filming and
you're like oh like that's a little
strange but then afterwards everyone's
always like oh yeah cool like what about
[ __ ] directors
no i've had great directors like i wish
your life sucks
i wish i could i don't think she said
dude yeah
i wish i could let you know to me have
an [ __ ] director and big [ __ ] that
guy i can't wait to tell that at a party
you know what i mean but i just answered
this question too um when you want to
have a uh sex scene in a [ __ ] any
movie or tv show you don't wear which
actress out there uh is the one for you
if i were to pick to have a seat yeah
um
i okay i'm not gonna say sexy but but
someone who i have a massive crush on is
vanessa hudgins oh yeah
hey send this to vanessa hudson okay to
say sexy i would love a sex scene with
vanessa hudgens and i'm totally
committed and engaged but come on
what happens in two years from now i'm
doing a movie with vanessa hutchins i
have a sex scene and then like someone
combs in and go he wanted this you know
what i mean it's like you never know
well then we got you by the way i get it
everything's not working listen i'm
white i'm white right now things aren't
good for us
i need to just be cool man next question
if you had to punch a black guy who
would it be first and last first and
last
when you do that sex scene with her can
you whisper in your ear and go i'm
soaring
honestly i was a huge high school
musical fan growing up i'm not gonna lie
of course that's where the origin story
started yeah that was your generation
yeah yeah you're fine
what's 50 cent's phone number
is there a 5 0 5 0 5 0 5 0 50 50 50 50
50 50.
how close do you feel to 50 cent where
you you you could call them by five now
right yeah can you call them just to
talk about like life
uh i don't here's the thing it's like
that boss thing so like you know you
wouldn't call him and be like hey i
could text and be like hey like um
you know what do you think about this
situation that you know what i mean did
you try to break that professional
barrier where you just like want to get
some hamburger today's video is brought
to you by draftkings
the moment we've been waiting for since
september is here in honor of the big
game draftking sports book an official
sports betting partner of super bowl 56
is giving new customers 56 to 1 odds on
either team bet just five dollars and
win
280 in free bets if your team wins
draftkings sportsbook is now live in new
york which means you can bet from almost
one third of the country if sportsbook
isn't in your state yet play draftkings
daily fantasy football contest for super
bowl 56
new customers can get a free shot at the
one million dollar top prize with their
first deposit download the draftking
sportsbook app use promo code off the
record and get 56 to 1 odds on either
team bet just 5 and get 280 in free bets
if your team wins that's promo code off
the record at draftking sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of super
bowl 56.
21 plus minimum age and location
requirements buried by jurisdiction
draftkings.com sportsbook for full list
of requirements and state specific
responsible gaming resources void where
prohibited gambling problem call 1-800
gambler in tennessee call or text the tn
redline
1-800-889-9789 in connecticut call
in new york call 888-789-7777 seven
seven eight h o p e n y or text h o p e
ny four six seven three six nine
download the draft team sports book app
use promo code off the record bet just
five bucks and get two hundred and
eighty dollars and free bets if your
team wins
he owns a club called taboo in uh new
york and we always go there me and our
like my co-star and he'll if he knows
we're there like the the bartenders or
whatever will text me your boys are here
sometimes he'll just show up and come
sit with us and hang out with us but
that's really like to the extent of it
but like the coolest thing ever was when
i wasn't really close with him and uh
the spin-off hadn't come out yet we had
just filmed a little of it um and i'd
only done like four episodes of power at
this time and he was like you know a
little drunk at uh one of the you know
uh parties for the things and he just
like was you know thank you so much to
everyone and he's like was looking
everyone he's like and braden and braden
that's my guy and that's my character
and i was like [ __ ] yeah like
so that was like a cool thing i was like
okay cool
it's gianni
that's just my character no big deal
call me whatever man [ __ ] me
you know when you play hockey like
there's always like fights and stuff
right has there been a time
where
it didn't need to be a fight but you're
just trying to find any reason to just
start sucking on a dude in hockey oh
yeah all the time oh all the time yeah i
got in a fight three weeks ago in a
men's league hockey game i beat the [ __ ]
out of some old guy
and it feels good it didn't feel great
but he um for no for no reason he got
his stick with one hand and just uh and
just hit my hand for no reason i'm like
because you were crushing them i got to
go work like it was crazy and i have i'm
like a hot head so i just turned around
i took off my gloves my helmet and i
just started feeding this guy and then
yeah
it was actually my last game before i
had to go to new york and start filming
again so they're like you got a four
game suspension i was like i'm thumping
the season anyways [ __ ] yeah
what's the under what uh like context
can you get into a fight and hockey it's
for any like we could just i could just
start sucking them for no reason usually
in professional hockey like say for an
example your team is down by like four
or five goals the fighter is like okay i
gotta [ __ ] like spark this up or
something i gotta gotta change this
round there's that there's that is like
the most common or if someone um
uh like absolutely lays out one of your
players you're like i can't let this
happen and the enforcer goes and beats
the [ __ ] out of the guy if you throw
gloves though i don't know [ __ ] about
hockey by the way but if you throw
gloves my understanding is as as if the
other guy throws gloves then you guys
can have a fight but otherwise you go in
the penalty box correct okay gotcha yeah
okay would you rather do uh
if you were if you were down to choosing
between two huge hockey movies to be a
actor in would you rather it be a comedy
or a drama
that is a great question yeah mighty
does
it wouldn't matter a comedy or drama it
would just be like who's um who wrote it
who's attached to it who are the other
people in it so because i my character
in power is literally like one scene
he's like a [ __ ] hard drug dealer and
then the next scene he's like so what
the [ __ ] we guys what are we doing today
like there's no like you can't put a
pulse on my character like he's dark and
then he's comedy so every day it's
different so i just live in that world
anyway so it's kind of all the same to
me um it would just be who's who's
attached better and you know stuff like
that we've reached the 12 minute and 57
mark this is part of show where we like
to um
turn up the heat change the temperature
into the heat and it goes up so um would
you
yes i've hooked up with a guy dude chill
out okay how do you guys [ __ ] watch
it for me
that's actually good i'm kidding i'm
kidding
do you have any serious life regrets
um no because everything i've ever done
has led me to this moment um and maybe
if i did one thing that i shouldn't have
then you know i wouldn't be here so i
feel like you just learn and you get to
a place where like you're here what has
been the greatest challenge of your life
because everything sounds glorious
i mean not like you got an astronaut in
the [ __ ] world and you're just
[ __ ] powerful
i put a lot of positivity out but like i
went through some [ __ ] hard times
like where i was homeless i didn't eat
like i worked three restaurant jobs like
i was taking six acting classes a week
like i got my car repossessed like i
didn't end up homeless
my lease ended on my apartment new york
la i was here i was just paying some guy
like a sublime he's like he thought he
was gonna stay another month he's like i
gotta come back uh next week and i was
like [ __ ] so i literally uh didn't have
a place to stay i had my hockey bag with
my clothes in it and i was walking
around l.a like i'm [ __ ] like i don't
know what to do how much money on the
bank account
like ten dollars maybe like nothing like
i was like i'm [ __ ] like i just got to
figure something out and luckily there
was a guy who's still one of my best
friends this day is my writing partner
he let me stay with them um for two
weeks and i wound up um you know getting
a i still had a restaurant job but every
dollar i had
just went into classes just got invested
back in my career i didn't put i didn't
put anything into like
any type of enjoyment like it was
literally everything for so that's why
i'm like i'm super positive i'm like
yeah i'm here like everything's great
but like
i went to some hard [ __ ] times um
and i think that's a given because you
guys are all here right now of course
you went through hard times to get to
this place um i just feel like it's kind
of cheesy like yeah like i slept in my
car this night it's like yeah everyone
had a hard time you know um sometimes
feeling a [ __ ] pillow in the bed
you're just like this is [ __ ] luxury
yeah yeah that's joe still yeah yeah
yeah yeah especially when he's high yeah
he's wearing the pillow for a long time
like we gotta drill yeah sometimes it's
the pillow and sometimes it's the
foursome with three girls you know what
i mean it's like
[ __ ] this guy
i know i just kidding i'm kidding
i stumbled into a
and i got these four girls in my car i'm
like this car's not big enough for all
of us
i gotta get a job
i gotta do better
man i gotta make it out the hood man
was there ever a co-star that you had
that you were intimidated to work with
octavia spencer yeah for sure right what
was that like working with her um it was
i was in so the first time i ever had a
chemistry read with her i read from ma
like four times i had a chemistry with
with her and the second i walked in and
she goes oh we got a young tom cruise
like immediately
made me feel comfortable and i was like
oh dope crushed the audition booked it
but then i was like oh that was her
making me feel comfortable now she's in
work mode when we get to set i get to
set the first day she's in the makeup
trailer in wigs like dancing and singing
with the mop like all this stuff when
she had to like murder someone and i'm
like i [ __ ] with this girl and she was
just immediately like cool as [ __ ] um
and yeah since then she's helped me so
much like my career life like everything
um
so would you do a sex scene with her a
hundred percent how much money i think
she's beautiful like she's like her
personality she's just like such like
like when she speaks like you're just
like i just think she's the [ __ ]
greatest person how much money we have
to pay you to text her right now and
call her octi
they uh her nickname's rock oh right how
did that happen yeah
okay most close yeah but i i don't think
i would uh text her and just say hey
octi
it's braided you know when you
crush an audition it's a it's a feeling
and a look that's what i always say like
like you're like okay i was in it and i
wasn't in my mind like oh my god they're
all looking at me as i'm saying my lines
are as i'm shooting because sometimes
you're in it but it's still not what
they're looking for yeah
you're right you are right but just
provide some context we've never crushed
an audition
what they're looking for and crushing it
yes crushing it is i did what i
prepared and what i wanted to do and it
went exactly according to plan the way i
prepared this character i was in the
moment i was listening and responding
and i don't know i wasn't in my head
that's crushing it to me now they'll
call you and go yeah you're totally
wrong for the part um that doesn't mean
like oh i didn't do well but i know four
girls i want to bang you yeah
that's how the person happens
in my mind that it doesn't mean like i
didn't do well it's just like oh i just
wasn't what they're looking for you know
that's what they such a casting director
bro i'm sorry you didn't get the part
yo i know three four girls that are
ready to [ __ ] you right now and they're
gonna be great for your couch by the way
i don't know
they're gonna be there
you guys are gonna have great chemistry
yeah that's awesome good for you man
okay what was your worst sexual
experience for [ __ ] sakes
for [ __ ] sake the worst sexual
experience
um
i
i mean all right so this is it's not it
wasn't like i've never really had like a
terrible sexual experience of course not
god of course not
um i mean there's a couple where i would
like really like regret it and i was
like oh i only lasted two hours one time
[Laughter]
i was like her teeth your teeth were so
big that was dangerous back there i
should be careful
there was one time where i i only made
someone come like four times and that
was like that was that was rough only
yeah that's a bird
[Laughter]
no i don't know there was one time where
there was like a beautiful girl in my
high school and i finally hooked up with
her and i wanted to for like years and
we had sex behind a sushi restaurant
she was like a tall model so her legs
couldn't fit in my back seat
so and i just remember um
uh i had hooked up actually like i'm
such a douchebag dude like you guys are
like oh [ __ ] this kid i hooked up i
hooked up with a girl like two hours
before this she had two hours before
this and then i left my friend's house
and i was heading home and this girl
texts me she's like i just broke up my
boyfriend i just like need to get him
off my mind like i want to hang out with
you so i like ripped my car out and i
was like yeah [ __ ] yeah so i went to her
house and i picked her up and went by
the sushi restaurant and i just had just
hooked up with someone and for some
reason like the way her legs are
positioned i could not get hard so i was
like hooking up with like this beautiful
girl and i literally was like no it's
[ __ ] dude it's just like it's perfect
and i was like hitting it i was like and
i just couldn't get hard it's working
i think i like kind of like you know you
do this orgasm
um but then i'm not but then so then i
went to go take her home and she was
like well i'll just uh blow you while um
while you drive so i was like okay
whatever so who are you bro i know i'm
sensitive
she's like why don't you do it i don't
want to i don't want to seem like it i'm
such a nice guy i donate to the chicks i
don't hate to save it we'll end it
[Laughter]
so i'm driving her home i'm driving her
home and she's blowing me so the ca uh i
get pulled over oh no
and then the cop starts blowing
[Laughter]
and there's a cop the cop keeps me
models and they all have sex with you
right i know how the story goes
yes smoking hot cop comes out
that's wishes for this back up they
start blowing you move your toe bro
swat team comes out all chicks with you
all models and that's the force to be
talking about
have you ever had a wet fart or anything
have you ever [ __ ] your pants i have
[ __ ] in my pants dude
oh my god all right she's blowing you so
she's just blowing me the compost is
over he comes up i'm like quickly like
my pants is still unbuckled he comes up
to the window um and he his reasoning
was that i looked young and i had a
provisional
i had a provisional driver's license
you're under you're underage you
shouldn't be driving this late so he
pulled me over and then he like gets my
license he looks at her he looks at my
pants unbuckled and he went
and he gave it back to me he's like go
right home wow
so it was cool but let's not forget that
i couldn't get my dick card like that
was embarrassing it's just a cop let you
go no problem he probably high-fived you
too and yeah they probably hugged you
it's like you're like the son i always
wish i had
you want to join the fort
you